welcome back to CBS morning's President
Biden has declared a major disaster in
Puerto Rico after Hurricane Fiona
brought catastrophic flooding to the
island as you see the homes have just
been destroyed the infrastructure
damaged and power was knocked out for
the entire Island the majority still
don't have power today this week our
lead National correspondent that would
be David begno has been reporting on the
island struggles with electricity and
adequate health care but five years
think about that five years after
Hurricane Maria he also found resiliency
and strength David joins us now from
Vega Baja David good morning glad you're
there to tell us the story good morning
good morning my friend good to see you
listen here's the deal Gail we came here
two weeks ago to work on this story we
had no clue hurricane Fiona was going to
come and the reality is with a million
Puerto Ricans U.S citizens by the way on
this island who don't have power they
can't even watch this story but they
were a part of helping us put it
together because at the end of the day
you can talk about a lot of human
suffering a lady who grew up here just
said to me David being raised here
taught me how to live in survival mode
but things are better they're looking
better they're feeling better and that's
what we came here to tell the story of
and it kind of starts with people just
like the man you're about to meet
Carlos Rodriguez and his team are
redefining the concept of farm to table
we say it's expensive to be poor in
Puerto Rico and so part of our dignity
list number one is good food good fresh
delicious healthy for them dignity
dignity Rodriguez is non-profit the
happy givers employs mostly retirement
age Puerto Ricans who grow Harvest
prepare and then deliver meals to
hundreds of the most needy people here
each and every week they're the heroes
they survive Irma Maria earthquakes
pandemics they're still smiling they're
still giving they're the true happy
givers I now have 15 moms in this
community right now pray for me that
take care of me that throw blessings
every time I come I have friends I have
amazing employees that really believe in
what we're doing raised in the southern
city of Ponce after Hurricane Maria
Rodriguez and his family left their
lives in North Carolina and returned to
Puerto Rico they bought this Sod Farm in
Vega Baja Lou ran into the storm so to
speak to help and if State and we like
to say this is not just a 30 second
video it's a 30-year vision and
hopefully David we won't be needed in 30
years it's foreign
says Rodriguez is part of a growing
trend of people who are rising from the
ruins of hurricane Maria five years
since Maria what's happened since you
could tell a story of nothing has
changed the power is still out we're
still struggling with a lot of things
such a different place you know in the
aftermath of hurricane Maria we became
emboldened and strengthened and said no
enough of this we want a different
Puerto Rico Bad Bunny may be the biggest
hit in music globally so much of his
music jarimar speaks to the issues on
this island yes yes you can see his his
soundtrack how it Chronicles the changes
in Puerto Rico estamos bien all about
the hurricane
was literally the soundtrack of the
resistance movement here it's a
different kind of assertion of
nationalism so with all the problems
this is where we want to be and his most
recent song apagon which means blackout
it starts being all about the problems
with the electric grid and oh another
blackout and how we experience all that
and then it transforms into this plea
that he says we just want to stay here
all I want is to be able to live here
Bonilla descends from a long line of
strong wrong women she considers her
mother and her 95 year old grandmother
among the activists who were still
making a difference in Puerto Rico's
future we want to change our country our
land our the society that we live in and
just help us do that but let us do it
let us Define what we want Puerto Rico
to be in the future we're in the midst
of an unprecedented reconstruction
permanent projects are happening as we
speak in January 2021 Pedro Pierre luisi
was elected governor he says it's his
top priority to rebuild the critical
infrastructure damaged five years ago so
how much money has Puerto Rico received
to help rebuild well just FEMA has
dispersed over five billion dollars
on the emergency
assistance projects this is basic
repairs and
individual assistants actually as
economic assistance to people who
suffered you know damages because of the
hurricane do you think Puerto Ricans
rely Less on the United States
government today than ever before I
think what we see often is that there
are these numbers of you know the U.S
government has approved these many
millions or billions of dollars
that doesn't always translate to these
communities independent journalist
Bianco grello also returned to live in
her native Puerto Rico in the wake of
hurricane Maria she wanted to cover the
untold stories and her reporting was
just featured in a recent documentary
released by Bad Bunny you have
communities growing their own food
collecting rain water
providing electricity through solar
panels because they don't trust that the
government can get it to them and
because they've lived through instances
where they've been lacking those
Services
grolosites Casa Pueblo as one shining
example of innovation with little
Federal funding for example solar panels
have been installed on the roofs of 13
businesses whose owners all agree to
provide critical services like medicine
refrigeration and cell phone charging
two residents during major power outages
like they're experiencing now so that
the barber now has reliable electricity
so that the bakery now has reliable
electricity and that we have an oasis so
that when we have an outage in at home
that's the people who don't have the
solar panels can come here connect your
devices and so that they're not Stranded
the Puerto Rican people will tell you it
is the communities coming together that
is helping them survive and that takes
us all the way back to the Good Deeds of
Carlos Rodriguez
one month and a half no water no water
no water and she's just expecting you
and sometimes
no light meet Victoria Ortiz she's a
stroke survivor who lives alone in Vega
Alta struggling to make ends meet
she told us softly how grateful she was
to get a helping hand from a happy Giver
I believe that the future of Puerto Rico
lies in its Community organizing because
when it's the people themselves that are
doing it you see a lot of successes and
even if the general picture might look a
little dim
these communities are showing the path
of what's possible
um David beg now you have done it again
you know you always find these things
that no matter how dire a situation is
there is always some kind of light
whether it's somebody famous like Bad
Bunny who certainly goes above and
beyond always for Puerto Rico to people
who we didn't know until today
that's the takeaway my friend as bad as
it may seem and the suffering is so real
there is a resilience and a smile Gail I
went into a flood zone this week and
when we left a man in his 80s handed me
a big old bag of avocados with a smile
on his face he had no power he had no
water in his home was flooded but he
wanted us to leave with something that
represents the Puerto Rican Spirit yes
David I mean you know that Spirit well
uh your coverage there began five years
ago you've been back consistently in
that time I'm curious on the end of uh
this trip uh how you're feeling about
the the Island's progress toward where
it wants to be your overall thoughts
where it wants to be overall thoughts it
wants to be less reliant on a government
that has consistently failed them and
promised to consistently deliver does
that make sense that's right off the top
of my head Tony it is frustrating to be
back here talking about some of the same
stuff but I promise you things are
getting better I hear it and and Puerto
Ricans because of Decades of
mismanagement really reject their
institutions and they're saying we just
want to be treated like people in the
states we are U.S citizens just treat us
fairly as one woman said closing thought
one girl said if you don't want to give
us the same amount of benefits here on
the island understand that we have your
passport and we can fly to Florida
tomorrow and then you've got to actually
take care of us like you take care of
everyone else boom keeping it real yeah
David you don't have to promise it
you're proving it with your coverage uh
thank you very much we appreciate it
just astounding work again thank you sir